so Donald Trump's taxes are back in the
news and have actually been subpoenaed
by the Manhattan district attorney state
prosecutors in Manhattan have subpoenaed
Donald Trump's accounting firm demanding
eight years of both Trump's personal and
business tax returns now the first
question we might ask is district
attorney if a district attorney is
issuing a subpoena for Donald Trump's
tax returns is this related to some kind
of investigation and the answer is that
yes it turns out that at the end of
August a criminal investigation was
opened up into those hush money payments
made by Donald Trump to mistresses and I
know many of us are completely fatigued
and sick of this hush money thing by now
and I'll sort of address that in a
second
these are the payments that were made
the payments were made in a in a literal
sense by trumps now in prison personal
attorney michael cohen but of course
they were made in service to Donald
Trump and Donald Trump as far as we know
reimbursed those payments to Michael
Cohen so that's the answer to question
one it's part of that investment a new
criminal investigation question two is
what's the full scope of this Manhattan
district attorney probe is it related
only to the 2016 hush money payments or
is there some broader campaign finance
or other investigation that this is part
of we don't know the answer to that we
know that one legal question about the
hush money particularly the payment made
to stormy Daniels is did Donald Trump's
business call that a legal expense in
their accounting which would be number
one hilarious and number two potentially
illegal and a felony if it was done to
conceal some other crime like tax
evasion or bank fraud or in the service
of some additional crime so we'll figure
that out maybe someday but let's get
more to what matters here and what
doesn't matter I understand we are
mostly sick of this entire hush money
payment thing the hush money payments
themselves as a way to punish Donald
Trump or make him suffer consequences
for the things that he did I believe
that that ship has sailed
we can as a practical matter vote Donald
Trump out
way faster than the hush money payment
investigation could even potentially
remove him from office it's just not
going to happen we shouldn't even be
thinking about that then we get to the
content of the tax returns themselves
that's actually what we're interested in
now that being said this is a district
attorney subpoena for an investigation
if they get the tax returns meaning if
the grand jury gets those tax returns
they would not even go public unless
they're leaked of course unless they end
up becoming evidence at a trial that is
also extremely unlikely to happen so I
don't really see this as something to be
optimistic about in terms of the
material getting to us for our review
but it's yet another thing that could
trigger Donald Trump first of all
secondly every time that we do hear
anything related to the content of
Donald Trump's taxes it's been something
that makes him look terrible so there is
still the potential here that if any of
this is released in any way leaked or
otherwise it's going to contain
extremely damaging information about
Donald Trump remember that when the
summaries of Donald Trump's tax returns
got out we learned that he lost just
like insane amounts of money and they
put out his attorney or someone put out
a statement saying oh this is all
calculated
you know he's gaming the system and this
is all because he's such a great
businessman people who were not working
for Trump who know about tax law and
accounting looked at it and said no no
no this is just the guy's really losing
a lot a lot of money or he lost a lot of
money in that time it would not be for
the tax benefits we also learned from
other tax disclosures of Trump that we
got a while ago that Donald Trump's dad
had financed a lot of Donald Trump's
failures we call that Rich Dad bails me
out just like the height of privilege
for someone claiming to be a self-made
man so this could be interesting if
something like that comes out it could
be interesting in that even just
fighting it could become a big story and
expensive for Donald Trump which would
be just delightful but as far as getting
rid of Trump as far as exposing
criminality the strategy remains the
same one that it's been for more than a
year vote Trump out in November of 2020
he'll be gone when a new president is
inaugural
in January of 2021 and it will be far
far more efficient than any of these
ideas related to tax returns or the 25th
amendment or impeachment I know the fans
of each of those individually will say
no those are great ideas David and they
may well be but they're not going to get
Trump out any faster than just voting
him out in November if you disagree with
me let me know